Kim Kardashian is a bona fide
I don't know who's more unfit to be a
parent oh yeah I saw you posted about
her this weekend yeah yeah what was
going on Connie's been silent for a
month yeah which is what you want he's
doing a lot better yeah what you want
when somebody is you know saying how
great Hitler is and how he likes the
Nazis and he likes all these people and
and uh who's clearly maybe in the middle
of a mental episode hopefully in the
middle of a mental episode not in the
middle of trying to become a Nazi right
in town for a month and then Kim is like
allowing her daughter to dress up as
Kanye and then she's being herself and
they're recreating like the Bound 2
video or whatever like that like
uh does it not seem like you're
instigating Kanye she is
what the [ __ ] is wrong with this woman
to give push back okay it's her dad she
loves her dad don't put it online first
of all look like me I don't know what
that's about yeah second of all you
don't need to do this publicly you don't
need to put this on tick-shock
this girl looked like me I look like a
girl a young girl
that's what's happening that's funny but
isn't this bad I mean don't put it
online it's very clearly but she's on
Tick-Tock like the young girl wants to
do like they know Tick Tock with your
dad your dad's experiencing a really
tough time right now just by rolling up
and make it more difficult for him even
if it's parenting that's good
hey let's consider your dad and like she
likes to say in every single interview
how great a parent she is and how she
never lets them you know uh what's it
called bad mouth or she never bad mouths
their father or whatever like that well
okay well if you care about her father
maybe say this might be hard for him to
digest at this what do you do when
there's a mentally ill guy on the train
he's like walking down like acting all
crazy do you start making you don't look
at them you stare at the ground and he
passes by you don't exist in this world
and now there's a there's a mentally ill
person around running around the world
and they're like provoking provoking
hands not mentally ill
I'm just like this is I don't know I
don't know if they know that I mean it
makes complete sense to me because who
is her mom yeah right she's from her
entire you know you become your parents
her parent literally pimped her out hey
let's put out a sex tape with you on it
we're gonna build an entire Empire off
of exploiting our children yeah I don't
care about the collateral damage this is
what it's going to be yeah that's what
she's doing and it's definitely not the
kid's fault North I don't think they had
anything no this is a child the child is
recreating her father that I'm sure she
loves very much which is an amazing
beautiful thing she can't she doesn't
even know what a Nazi is yet
I mean how old is the kid she's probably
like eight I know I don't know what
Nazis work with when you're eight well I
heard people talk about Hitler when I
was in like first grade my brother was
talking about like who is this guy
[Laughter]
Indians in this house eight years old
what grade is that second maybe third
yeah may not talk about them yeah dude I
I mean okay so she does know about that
Mark still I just can't make the [ __ ]
video if she does know what a Nazi is
and she's making the video he knew in
kindergarten you were getting recruited
she's nine years old the youth maybe
she's nine she's nine years old yeah
it's like nine she's a nine years old he
doesn't know the repercussions
[Laughter]
I mean
I just can't believe it I saw the video
and I can't believe it's one thing if
she did it by herself and uploaded and
Kim didn't know what's going on Kim is
in the video with her yes this is
choreographed is it because music Kim
doesn't realize how provoking no this is
impossible she's a [ __ ] idiot maybe
that's also possible yeah is it possible
that she loves the drama associated with
her husband is it possible that she's
trying to rile them is it possible she's
found a way to make us feel bad for
Kanye like because she find orchestrated
a magical way where we're fine we're
like oh God I hope Kanye doesn't see
this
like
yeah I mean I don't think anyone's
actually gonna feel bad for Connie yeah
but I do I mean it just does seem like a
clear like provocation I don't really
know what the I feel bad for Kanye I
feel bad for Kanye he's watching his
daughter who he has no access to
like you're doing this I can't see this
girl yeah she's dressing as me she's a
[ __ ] hostage I can't see my daughter
isn't that great he can't see her based
off his actions and now that's fine
that's based on my action but now you're
gonna rub my face in it by putting my
daughter on Tick Tock which I've already
already adamantly spoken out against and
for a guy with a lot of batshit crazy
views this is a very logically sound
view now I don't want my nine-year-old
oh I'm Roundup
on Tick Tock so now not only going to
take me from my kid which Maybe I
Deserve but you're gonna do this thing
that we all know is horrendous putting a
nine-year-old girl with millions of
eyeballs on her on Tick Tock in the same
way that her mom got traumatized about
an even younger age and you're gonna
just rub my face in it and I can't do
[ __ ] about it not to mention even if
those actions are my own fault let me
get hurt don't hurt my dog he doesn't
want his kids so I felt it out I hear
that the fire but like your point before
she is used to being pimped out by her
mom this is her form of love yeah they
attention is currency to them so she's
in the video so to get her [ __ ] popping
because nobody's clicking on North [ __ ]
without Kim in it or more people will
click because Kim's in it and you're
going to now deny her daughter
to express how she her love and Devotion
to her dad yes and make a tick tock
video yes that's being parenting is it's
being better than the generation yeah
she's already on Tick Tock so now that
she's off I can take you off Tick Tock
you're nine years old you one of my kids
don't even wrote my sex tape on Roblox
okay so Tick Tock is the problem not
this video no wait are you saying all of
it's a problem are you saying that she
should be in it to get her kid more
views on Tick Tock no no I think yeah I
think Kim's in the video to get her kid
more abusive yeah this is the only thing
that's good parenting no no I'm saying
that this video isn't that bad even
though yes what you're saying is Kim is
trying to build up her Tick Tock yeah
but it like I'm sure this Kanye is not
happy about it but I'm saying that I
think the place and in the attention for
our North is like hey I love my dad I
just want to show my Dad how about this
how about this right I mean North didn't
do anything wrong no no no I think the
Kim didn't do anything wrong okay well
how about this how about this right I'm
Kim Kardashian I say that Kanye cannot
be around our children right
I'm also Kim Kardashian I'm allowing our
daughter to dress up as Kanye and I'm
going to post a video on that app that
Kanye hates
that her his daughter is on it's
insensitive to Kanye
not only is it insensitive
it's saying
Kanye is going my kids probably miss me
then he sees a video of his daughter
dressed up as him and he still can't
access her he's going damn my daughter
misses me so much she's dressing up but
she needs me in her light it's basically
saying you can't have her you can't have
her I wasn't saying I should when she
was trying to be happy and Kanye's
making death videos I will never defend
him I'll never defend him Kim doesn't
have she does it oh Kanye's [ __ ] no no
no Kanye
it's [ __ ] up we all know this yeah and
he was super [ __ ] up to her but two
people could be [ __ ] up
and just because it was less [ __ ] up
than the other person doesn't mean what
they're doing is good it just means it's
less [ __ ] up no okay we all are in
agreeance that the kid shouldn't be on
Tick Tock but the fact that she's
allowing the kid to be on Tic-Tac I just
don't think that this video is that bad
because the provocation of Kanye I don't
think she cares and she shouldn't care
[ __ ] her over so many times how about
this you you got a baby [ __ ] you got a
baby mom right you got a baby mama no
but imagine right like so we know yeah
so I was like you and your wife or you
your baby you guys you got a kid okay
your wife takes your kid says you're not
allowed to see your kid at all
your kids post on Tick Tock as you this
person you can't speak to can't be in
their life at all
aren't you gonna go and the mom is
dancing in the video to your [ __ ] aren't
you gonna be like is this [ __ ] sending
shots at me yes like and don't use my
kid our kid as a pawn even if you're
upset at me first of all I'm pretty sure
she'd have [ __ ] up things in too I'm
reporting to him she [ __ ] Chris Paul
while they were still together I'm
pretty sure North wanted to do this I
don't think Tim you're gonna put on his
makeup do you think that they're the
same like they have the same level of
authority the nine-year-old girl and her
mom you're the mom your job is not to
upset your your husband or whatever it
is to constantly protect your child do
the best thing for your child and if
you're gonna do a shitty thing to your
child and upset your ex-husband who
might be crazy
you think that's good parenting in any
way shape or form like I said where she
should have her kids taken from her too
hey JP Morgan take her money we just
disagree on that this video is bet I
think her being on tick tock
in in entirety is bad but I just think
this video isn't bad this is just her
daughter wanting to show some love to
her dad
like that's what I see when I see this
video I haven't watched a video because
she looked too much like me but you
actually do want to see it no she looked
like she don't even want to be in that
[ __ ] video son what the [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] she didn't do anything that's how
Kanye was in the video he was just a
stone face though but do you think it's
good parenting or bad parent I think
it's bad parenting that she's on tick
tock but do you think making the video
and provoking Kanye as bad parenting no
I I don't I think Kim has not she
doesn't owe anything to Kanye and no she
don't send me to her kids certainly yeah
and I think the kid wants to do this and
I think the kid gets enjoyment out of
this and you can be as a parent but the
kid wants to eat candy for dinner do you
think it's good now we're going back to
being on Tick Tock no no but he's a good
parent bad parent do the specific video
because this video to me is not good for
the kid it's worse pain I don't think
how's the kid affected the kid the kid
is acting as a proxy either her parents
like divorce battle nah but the kid
wants to do this the kid's like oh hey I
love my dad and the what's happening to
her dad or what she's doing to her dad
the Kurds want to attack the whoever is
in control in Iraq
America gives them some weapons so they
can attack him even better
it puts the batter in their back right
now you have a proxy war the kids being
used as a proxy for one parent to get at
the other parent okay that's bad
parenting and as for that reason Kim
should say hey we can make the video but
we're not going to put it out because
that is going to make your dad feel some
type of way and we don't want to use you
to make your dad feel like that and then
making your dad feel like that actually
might make him stay in this state that
he's in longer which would be longer
time away from you now you could make
the argument she's trying to do this on
purpose to induce another [ __ ] crazy
reaction from Kanye and then get his
rights to those kids completely stripped
let's make that [ __ ] go crazy
again and then we take it to the courts
I want full custody this guy gets
nothing look he's insane he's a Nazi and
he just did this insane [ __ ] again
trying to steal the kids that I would I
would not put that faster and that's
[ __ ] up